[Musica]
[Applauso]
considerate la vostra semenza Fatti non
foste a viver come bruti ma perseguitar
virtute e canoscenza
se Dante Alighieri
fosse vivo oggi
che cosa farebbe se il sommo poeta
vivesse ai giorni d'oggi che cosa
farebbe io me lo sono chiesto tante
volte me lo sono chiesto perché sono
nato proprio in mezzo alla toscana a 20
minuti Dove è nato Dante e a 20 minuti
Dove è nato Leonardo da Vinci e quindi
quando nasce in una terra che ha già
dato due geni di questo calibro ti metti
l'anima in pace e cerchi di imparare da
loro anzi cerchi anche di essere alla
loro altezza all'altezza delle nostre
origini della nostra cultura e allora me
lo sono chiesto spesso che cosa avrebbe
fatto Dante Alighieri oggi
Per prima cosa avrebbe aggiornato
sicuramente il suo inferno avrebbe Prima
di tutto creato una nuovo girone Per
quanto riguarda i leoni da tastiera
avrebbe fatto una Bolgia dedicata agli
influencer effimeri che creano tutta una
serie di contenuti inutili avrebbe poi
fatto bruciare nelle fiamme eterne
quelli che creano fake news e bufale i
seminatori di discordia e i consiglieri
fraudolenti quelli ce l'aveva già anche
lui ai suoi tempi sono quelli che ancora
oggi creano guerre distruzione causano
il mondo di ignavi era pieno nel
Medioevo Ed è pieno oggi gli ignavi
sapete chi sono Sono quelli che vissero
senza lode e Senza infamia sono quelli
che non presero mai una decisione Ma è
una posizione che non si misero mai in
gioco e Dante li mette addirittura
nell'antiferno nel vestibolo e dice di
loro Non ti curar di loro ma guarda e
distanza E allora una volta che ha
aggiornato il suo inferno come
comunicherebbe oggi la Divina Commedia
Dante Alighieri se fosse vivo io ci ho
pensato sicuramente non potrebbe usare
le rime che in qualche modo ha usato lui
quando ha scritto la Divina Commedia da
701 anni fa non potrebbe usare i canti
come aveva fatto però molto
probabilmente farebbe la stessa
operazione mentale che fece proprio
tanti anni fa
immaginatevi per un attimo di tornare
indietro nel tempo per un attimo
immaginatevi un'epoca completamente
diversa dalla nostra immaginatevi di
tornare nel Medioevo
Guardate che In quell'epoca là la gente
non sapeva né leggere né scrivere e le
poche persone che sapevano leggere e
scrivere lo facevano in latino in latino
si diceva la messa e gli ecclesiastici
usavano il latino in latino veniva usato
da avvocati e notai per redigere tutta
una serie di documenti i diplomatici
facevano i trattati in latino e anche
Dante Alighieri lo conosceva molto molto
bene ma lui decide di scrivere l'opera
più bella di tutti i tempi in volgare in
volgare la lingua del Volgo la lingua
del Popolo Dante l'aveva già usata in
passato il volgare l'avevo usato nel
dolce Stilnovo Tanto gentile e tanto
onesta farla donna mia quand'elia tu
Saluta dai la conoscete tutti quanti
l'abbiamo studiata Ed ecco che stavolta
però per fare la Divina Commedia
nel giro di osare di più decide di fare
una cosa che normalmente a quei tempi
non si faceva decide di parlare della
materia più elevata cioè di Dio in
volgare cioè di usare la lingua del
Popolo per parlare di Dio e così non si
fa e non va bene e tutti contro Dante Ma
noi sappiamo che ha vinto lui oggi
perché noi italiani stiamo usando la sua
lingua si dice che delle 2000 parole che
normalmente noi usiamo tutti i giorni
nella nostra linguaggio quelle più usate
ben 1600 si trovano esattamente Nella
Divina Commedia nella stessa accezione
quindi Dante padre della lingua italiana
quindi Dante padre della cultura
italiana quindi Dante padre dell'Italia
e questa operazione al popolo al Volgo
alle persone comuni detentore agli
artigiani piacque subito ed impararono
la Divina Commedia a memoria se la
trasmettevano per via orale non sapevano
né leggere né scrivere ma sapevano
declamare i versi di Dante e lo facevano
non solo perché la Divina Commedia era
bella non solo perché era una bella
storia non solo perché era potente Ma
perché suonava bene Era musica
Nel mezzo del cammin di nostra vita mi
ritrovai per una selva oscura che la
diritta via era smarrita Allora si mosse
io li tenne dietro per me si va nella
città dolente Per me si va nell'interno
dolore per me si va tra la perduta gente
lasciate ogni speranza voi che Entrate
vuolsi così colà dove si puote ciò che
si vuole più non dimandare Amor che
Annulla amato amar perdona galeotto fu
il libro e chi lo scrisse colui che la
difesa ha viso aperto la bocca sollevò
dal fiero Pasto e quindi uscimmo a
riveder le stelle
musica
era qualcosa di incredibile E allora
cosa farebbe oggi Dante Alighieri visto
che a suo tempo ha innovato spazzando
via il latino e dandoci il volgare e a
contaminato Io lo so cosa farebbe per
raccontare la sua Divina Commedia
userebbe i social ma non userebbe tutti
i social userebbe Tik Tok
conoscete Tik Tok ce l'avete Tik Tok è
quella app che tra i giovani tra i
giovanissimi spopola è fatta di balletti
di piccoli video di Trend ed è un'App in
cui i nostri giovani stanno lì anche ad
ore si stanno comodi comodi sul loro
divani nei loro mondi virtuali E questa
app è spesso oggetto anche di
discussione però è qualcosa che ormai
esiste ed è qualcosa che in qualche modo
coinvolge i nostri ragazzi i nostri
ragazzi non leggono più
o se leggono leggono poco o in maniera
forzata quasi costretti dopo due anni di
pandemia sono tornati sui banchi di
scuola sono tornati nella vita reale da
fuggendo dai loro mondi virtuali e hanno
trovato una scuola che magari sta
parlando del linguaggio che non sono
simili ai suoi simili ai nostri giovani
che in qualche modo sono un po' più
lenti meno pieni di effetti speciali E
allora
spesso in questi momenti quando magari
trovano Qualche professore noioso che
gli fa fare la parafrasi della Divina
Commedia la parafrasi Ecco che magari è
proprio in quel momento che invece di
amarla la Divina Commedia incominciano
ad odiarla ma non solo i nostri ragazzi
non hanno una vera educazione digitale e
allora sono lasciati soli con i loro
smartphone dove passano ore ed ore e
sono soggetti ai rischi che normalmente
possono accadere
cyberbullismo ansia depressione
isolamento
pedofilia e anche tutta una serie di
frode informatiche che spesso accadono E
allora cosa dobbiamo fare
conoscete le Challenge sono quelle sfide
che vengono fatte su Tik Tok su tiktok
io faccio una cosa in un certo modo lui
la fa in un certo un altro una sorta di
balletto di modo di dire e di azione
tutti fanno la stessa cosa Ma a loro
modo e poi diventa virale
facendo una di queste Challenge una
bambina di 11 anni di Palermo
rimase impiccata e morì E allora tutti i
moralisti subito a puntare il dito tutti
a dire che i social sono una piaga
sociale sono il demonio E allora tutti a
dire che tiktok non andava bene
la Tik Tok è una piattaforma è una
piattaforma neutra e la tecnologia si
sta non è quello che è ma è quello che
gli fai fare un bisturi può uccidere o
può curare Quindi il problema non è la
tecnologia Ma è l'uso che se ne fa della
tecnologia Il problema non è la
tecnologia Ma è l'educazione che noi
diamo sulla tecnologia E allora come
possiamo fare per non lasciare
da soli i nostri ragazzi con questi
Smartphone in mano isolati a cercare di
vivere comodi nei loro mondi virtuali
sui divani Beh io ci ho pensato e a me è
venuto in mente Dante mi è venuta
veramente Dante perché lui avrebbe
innovato E contaminato contaminato E
innovato innovate contaminato E allora
quando sono arrivati i 70 i 700 anni di
Dante l'hanno passato io che sono nato a
50 anni fa proprio in mezzo alla toscana
a 20 minuti da Dante a 20 minuti da
Leonardo che cosa ho fatto Mi sono messo
su Tik Tok e ho portato la Divina
Commedia su Tik Tok non bisogna aver
paura dei social o della tecnologia
bisogna riempirli di buone pratiche e di
buoni contenuti e portando la Divina
Commedia È stata un'impresa titanica per
me Cento Canti in 20 minuti raccontati
in una settimana e naturalmente quando
mi sono approcciata questo social io non
l'avevo mai fatto e allora prima di
cominciare però invece di buttarmi ho
cercato di imparare il loro linguaggio
sono stato tre mesi sulla piattaforma a
studiare Poi ho creato un Format poi ho
cercato di fare una pianificazione e poi
sono uscito dalla mia zona di comfort e
sono andato in cammino alla ricerca
della retta via di come si utilizza nei
social uscendo dalla mia selva oscura
però c'era qualcosa che ancora non mi
tornava perché c'era qualcosa che dovevo
capire fino in fondo e ho capito che
questi Social come tiktok sono Social in
cui i ragazzi si divertono
E allora per trasmettere la Divina
Commedia ai ragazzi dovevo divertirmi
dovevo essere io il primo divertirmi e
mi sono divertito mi sono divertito
tantissimo Essi sono divertiti anche
loro perché sono arrivati In flotta Io
non me l'aspettavo Ma sono arrivati
27.000 follower E stanno ancora
crescendo 8,4 milioni di visualizzazioni
un qualcosa di incredibile Io non mi
immaginavo che su Tik Tok la Divina
Commedia potesse avere un successo di
questo tipo ma non solo Tik Tok Italia
che mi chiama per diventare un Creator
cioè un creatore di contenuti per la sua
Community in Italia non solo la notizia
che va sui giornali alla televisione
sulle radio e quindi tutti sanno che la
Divina Commedia è sbarcata su Tik Tok
Ma la cosa più bella è avvenuta dopo la
cosa più bella è stata quando la sera
dopo cena io mi mettevo a spiegare i
canti e allora facevo le dirette le live
e all'inizio sono arrivati in centinaia
poi migliaia e tutti a riempirmi di
domande Qualcosa di incredibile presto
presto Ho bisogno della spiegazione del
canto Quinto quello di Paolo e Francesca
perché domani ho l'interrogazione la
cantica del Purgatorio per favore la
cantica del Purgatorio perché ho la
verifica tu mattina o italiana alla
prima ora mi servirebbe sapere come ha
fatto il conte Ugolino a mangiare ai
suoi figli Ecco che quindi è stato
qualcosa di impressionante vedere come
tanti ragazzi
dialogassero e parlassero e
apprezzassero la Divina Commedia Cioè
non ero io che facevo Dante Era come se
Dante arrivasse ragazzi e parlasse a
tutti loro come se fosse ancora vivo
oggi come se fosse ancora un amico dei
ragazzi
però i ragazzi mi facevano tutti la
stessa domanda scusi ma a lei ma è un
prof
e io No non sono non sono un prof Anzi
non ci credevano io anzi ho fatto
ingegneria sono un imprenditore digitale
sono semplicemente un grande
appassionato un grande fan di Dante e
non ci credevano e quando cercavo di
spiegarvelo mi dicevano sempre tutti
quanti
Peccato che non insegna perché se avesse
avuto un professore come lei non avrei
odiato la Divina Commedia ma l'avrei
amata
è questo quello che dobbiamo fare
è questo quello che è il nostro dovere
dobbiamo non lasciare da soli i nostri
ragazzi Dobbiamo anche noi stare accanto
Popolare i social network riempirli di
buone pratiche e di buoni contenuti
dobbiamo respirare la loro stessa area
dobbiamo
respirare il loro stesso ossigeno
ora più che mai ora più che mai e per
farlo dobbiamo essere all'altezza di
quello che fece Dante 700 anni fa
innovare e contaminare e contaminare e
innovare innovare e contaminare ora più
che mai dobbiamo imparare nuovi
linguaggi conoscere non aver paura
uscire dalla nostra zona di comfort
uscire dalla nostra selva oscura e
cercare di essere all'altezza del nostro
passato della nostra cultura delle
nostre radici che ancora oggi deve
innovare e contaminare
e dobbiamo fare esattamente quello che
farebbe Dante Oggi dovremmo fare la
stessa cosa che ha fatto lui 700 anni fa
perché
Fatti non foste a viver come bruti ma
perseguitar tute e canoscenza grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]